Red Sox of 04. Norman Kevin Millar
saying hey don't let us win just one
Johnny Damon was on that team he's got
the ring to show for it and so the
Boston Red Sox the only team to do that
in Major League Baseball come back from
3-0 never happened in the NBA but the
Celtics have a chance now they do at
home on Monday
yeah they do this is what they wanted
you know everybody you know including
Kenny myself we thought they were Ghana
or they fought back and they you know
you're Jaden Brown before the game talk
about making history they get a chance
to making history I'm just wondering for
the Heat
to lose like that but like you know what
I was going to say when you asked me
that question Shaq 0.5 can they come
back yes can they come back from that I
do remember
here in the NBA Finals when the San
Antonio Spurs lost a game six like that
they didn't win the series however they
didn't die they didn't just lay down he
played a great game seven and just
happened to lose and you have to be a
special group you want to do that well
you have to have a special leader and I
actually like what spoker said he says
we'll be ready for sun uh Monday yeah I
love what he said we it was a lot of
noise going on he should be ready
you have totally flipped well I'm gonna
tell you something because I saw bad
Celtic tonight
that's not the same team I saw in game
four and five I saw it for a half then
the second half I was like yo these
dudes Just Gonna Keep screwing around so
so you started these this series picking
the Celtics yes
then they are the best team yeah but you
see how they have these lapses like
first they had three games elapses they
had two games of they are the best team
they had a half to death like
a a friend of mine who's one of the
greatest coaches ever he says he can't
beat them but the shelters can let them
win that's exactly how I look at this
series so who wins Monday
I'm concerned for the Celtics
because they went back to games one two
and three tonight well we're just gonna
keep jacking up threes even though they
shot 71 percent in the first half 66 in
the second half from twos but they gonna
just keep shooting threes but you
wouldn't be super
confident if you're the Boston Celtics
and you get to a game seven I don't know
because no I'm just saying that every
Championship run even when you guys this
team ain't won the championship no I'm
saying this team ain't won the
championship every Championship run no
no that you've been in even when you did
not win it on I've never changed that
you had to win that I've never had these
people I never had these peaks in The
Valleys that the Celtics have I listen
we've lost game but this go from hey
we're gonna just keep jacking up the
reason we making we're gonna look good
they're eight minutes from going back to
back they would they report suck they
didn't win no title left but they're
going that doesn't matter I agree I
agree with you get there in my
Championship run we did have lapse and
you have to have ugly games especially
you gotta win I'm just telling you this
was uh the second half of the Celtics
but I'm concerned for the year because
that's a tough way to lose and it's it's
not like it's four seconds five seconds
that was Point that's a good punch man
yeah man you went up but check they
didn't play well oh
yeah
I can say first of all they got a great
coach he's going he said he's gonna have
them ready but if I'm the heat I'm like
gosh
our two best players played as bad as
they can play
that's what I would say as the guys
we're nine for 36. I said Jim is not
going to play that bad's not gonna play
that bad and you know the one thing they
got on the road you sure about that
there's not a single person in America
right now I think that he's gonna win
this game can I ask you something I'm
not saying that you're wrong or right
Chuck I'm just saying that in terms of
mindset so okay I agree with you that's
how the heat can feel but also if you're
the Celtics you can feel
now we had them they you know they can't
we could get up on them so easily all we
have to do is sustain it as BR as Jalen
we sustain it it's over so they're both
gonna have a a battle cry but I know
that but I'm saying
all the heat all the pressure was on the
Heat tonight now you think you're also
on the Celtics hell yes hell yeah yeah
no no no no no because let me tell you
something if the heat if the Celtics
lose game seven at home all this we
making history gonna be like yo man
y'all didn't make no damn history y'all
got to game seven and y'all did so all
depression right now goes back to the
Celtic it was the one to me I said it
before I said all the pressure was on
the Heat tonight now it flips all the
pressure is on the Celtics so you're
thinking he can bounce back from that
gut punch I think if you got leaders
like air exposure Jimmy Butler bam out
of Bayou and them other guys Gabe Benson
just plays because that's a tough way to
lose I know it's a tough way to lose hey
let me tell you something Kenny makes a
great point when reality hit that three
against the Spurs I says Ain't No Way
those guys gonna have a chance in game
seven but because the great Greg
Popovich and those guys that game seven
people forget it went down to the wire
I'm not saying the heat is going to win
of course I'm gonna pitch the Celtics I
sent it I said I don't think they got a
chance of winning game seven the 51
Knicks the 94 nuggets the 0-3 Blazers
all forced to game seven all lost the
Celtics will try on Monday night in game
seven to become the first team to come
back from that city is going to be on
fight yeah and we will be there for game
seven and by the way that is game seven
number 158 in uh history that you'll see
I I agree with you brother hey little
Henry oh yeah hello Charlie I guarantee
you chuck could see you big part one of
them
by the time you see him again he's not